Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Hélène VERNET
Je crois au Dharma, au destin,
à un sens de mission,
qui est là pour nous expliquer
pourquoi nous sommes sur cette planète.
Le mien, apparemment,
est lié aux télécommunications.
Mon grand-père était un des pionniers
de cette industrie au Brésil,
et moi, un siècle après,
j'y travaille toujours.
Donc, j'ai ce sens de mission
qui vient d'une tradition familiale.
Je suis également un des experts
des Nations Unies en villes intelligentes,
et nous travaillons sans cesse
pour développer des méthodologies
qui sont appliquées partout dans le monde
pour rendre la vie
des citoyens plus vivable,
dans un cadre plus agréable
et surtout plus efficace.
J'ai aussi un rêve.
Et mon rêve, c'est de
combattre la fracture numérique,
d'aider les populations les plus pauvres
et les plus vulnérables de la planète,
telles que les tribus indigènes
et les réfugiés dans
les camps aujourd'hui.
Ce sens de mission, mon intérêt
pour ce domaine m'a amené
à passer, récemment, une semaine
dans la peau d'un réfugié.
Je suis allé jusqu'à la frontière
entre la Syrie et la Turquie
j'ai [traversé] toute la Turquie
jusqu'à l'île de Lesbos en Grèce
pour mieux comprendre
comment ça se passe
quand on est
sur le chemin des réfugiés.
Avant de vous donner les conclusions
que j'ai tirées de ce voyage,
de cette expérience,
je vais vous raconter une anecdote
pour vous donner un angle
assez particulier sur cette problématique.
Pour moi, la connectivité
est un droit universel.
Ce n'est pas encore la loi,
mais je pense que bientôt, ça va l'être.
L'anecdote est liée à une situation.
Je vous emmène à Vienne
en septembre 2015.
L'Autriche recevait, à l'époque,
des milliers de réfugiés
sur leur chemin
vers des pays plus au nord.
La ville avait préparé le vélodrome
pour accueillir jusqu'à 8 000 réfugiés,
avec l'hébergement, la nourriture,
tout ce qu'ils voulaient,
du moins ce dont la ville
imaginait qu'ils avaient besoin.
Par contre, ils avaient
un besoin encore plus urgent.
Pour moi, c'était étonnant, et je pense
que ça va être pareil pour vous :
c'était le wifi.
Une grande partie des réfugiés
qui arrivaient au vélodrome
ont refusé de rester
parce qu'il n'y avait pas le wifi.
(Rires)
Ce n'était pas pour s'amuser, mais
pour planifier le reste de leur voyage
pour aller en Allemagne, en Suède, etc.
Ils doivent rester en contact
avec les amis, la famille,
donc le wifi est absolument essentiel.
Quand on n'a pas de lien avec la société,
on est dans un nouveau pays,
on risque beaucoup de choses
si on n'a pas cette connexion.
Je voudrais partager
une hypothèse avec vous.
Vous connaissez peut-être la pyramide
des besoins humains de Maslow.
Il y a la première version ;
l'hypothèse, c'est la deuxième version.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
L'hypothèse indique que, dans
certains cas, les réfugiés viennent -
c'est un exemple qu'il faut considérer -
et la connectivité est plus importante
que les besoins physiologiques.
Si on garde ça en tête,
on commence à comprendre pourquoi
ils se promènent avec leur smartphone.
C'est la seule façon qu'ils ont
de ne pas se perdre,
de trouver le bon chemin
et d'éviter des problèmes de violence.
La connectivité est très importante
pour tout le monde ;
dans leur cas, elle est essentielle.
On continue le voyage.
Je vous emmène en Syrie,
donc bienvenue en enfer.
Je ne vais pas vous expliquer
la difficulté de cette situation,
parce que les médias vous
bombardent d'informations,
avec des images, avec des
vidéos et toutes les histoires.
Je veux par contre peut-être clarifier
quelques éléments supplémentaires
qui ne sont pas connus du public.
Cette guerre est géopolitiquement
extraordinairement complexe.
Il y a des acteurs visibles, cachés,
ça traîne depuis presque six ans,
et les spécialistes commencent à indiquer
que cette guerre n'aura pas de fin.
Donc, on se trouve dans
un contexte assez nouveau.
Il y a une dynamique qui va continuer.
Donc, si on sort de la Syrie,
en sachant très bien que c'est
le contexte auquel on fait face,
il est facile de comprendre pourquoi
ils viennent en masse vers l'Europe.
Ils n'ont plus d'options.
Ceux qui ont l'argent
pour payer un contrebandier
pour essayer de venir
ici et risquer leur vie, ils le font.
Ils ne le font pas tous
pour la même raison,
mais je pense qu'il est juste de dire
que la vaste majorité
est dans ce genre de contexte.
Et donc, pour moi, c'est très simple.
C'est un seul mot : ils sortent
de l'enfer pour trouver l'espoir.
C'était bien le cas entre 2015 et 2016.
En 2015, c'était affreux :
un million de réfugiés sont arrivés,
500 000 étaient des Syriens,
3 800 réfugiés sont décédés, noyés,
ou ont disparu en chemin.
On a déjà un million
de demandeurs d'asile syriens.
Ceux qui sont venus
dans les cinq dernières années,
ils demandent à s'établir en Europe.
C'est quand même la loi,
ils ont la possibilité de le faire.
Par contre, il y avait avant la guerre
21 millions de Syriens.
Il y a déjà un million qui ont trouvé
une possibilité de venir
habiter ici ou ailleurs, formellement.
Mais il y en a encore 20 millions qui
peuvent considérer ce genre de chemin.
Et si on pensait autrement ?
Si on essayait de changer
cette équation pour exporter l'espoir
vers les pays limitrophes
autour de la Syrie, qui accueillent
plus de 90 % de la population
des réfugiés qui a quitté le pays ?
Est-ce qu'on peut faire ça ?
Et qui a l'obligation de faire ça ?
Il faut clarifier une chose
très importante :
il y a une deuxième convention de Genève.
Celle des droits de l'homme est très
connue, mais il y a une convention de 1951
qui a été signée par 147 pays,
pour les droits des réfugiés.
Aider les réfugiés n'est pas une option
mais une responsabilité mondiale partagée.
On n'est pas en train de rendre service,
on est obligé de le faire.
Il s'agit juste de décider quelle
est la meilleure façon d'y arriver.
Passons aux situations concrètes.
Continuons le voyage vers la Jordanie.
Le camps d'Al Za'atari est
le deuxième plus grand au monde.
Il y a 85 000 réfugiés, plus ou moins,
et il ressemble à ça.
Ça ressemble à une agglomération
en plein désert,
avec un centre-ville, des quartiers, etc.
Par contre, ce n'est pas une ville.
Ça n'a pas été construit pour être une
ville mais un hébergement temporaire.
Normalement, on accueille les gens
en attendant de trouver une solution
pour les établir dans un autre pays,
si c'est ça qu'ils demandent.
Ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui.
Je vous pose une question,
une petite devinette :
selon vous, après cinq,
presque six ans de guerre,
combien de réfugiés ont été
officiellement réinstallés,
avec un permis de travail,
les enfants à l'école,
et la possibilité de vivre
une vie normale ? Combien ?
Levez la main si vous pensez
que plus de 50 % des réfugiés
sont déjà dans cette situation.
Plus de 10 % ?
OK, vous avez raison, parce que
la réalité est très dure : 3,6.
Seulement 3,6 % d'un million
après presque six ans !
En plus, ça, c'est la bonne nouvelle,
parce que la moyenne mondiale
pour tous les réfugiés,
pas que les Syriens,
est de 1 %.
On se trouve dans une situation où on
fait semblant de résoudre les problèmes.
On les met dans les camps
parce que ça fait partie du processus,
et on les oublie,
on les oublie très longtemps.
Pendant 17 ans, c'est la moyenne.
Il y a des réfugiés palestiniens
qui sont là depuis plus de 30 ans,
dans des bidonvilles au Liban,
c'est la nouvelle réalité.
Donc le problème est résolu.
Il a juste disparu mais, pour les gens,
ça veut dire qu'il n'y a plus
de problème à résoudre.
Donc, il faut faire quelque chose,
travailler avec les gouvernements,
avec les agences comme les
Nations Unies, et toutes les ONG
déjà dans le secteur pour essayer
de les aider en tant que société civile.
Donc j'ai une proposition.
J'ai ici une possibilité,
plus qu'une proposition,
c'est juste de se dire :
« Et si on essayait de donner
le genre de connexion
qu'on a ici tous les jours ? »
On s'habitue de façon quotidienne,
on est en train de respirer de l'Internet,
et on ne se rend même pas compte
de l'importance de tout ça.
Les réfugiés ont encore leur smartphone,
ils peuvent le charger dans les camps,
mais ils n'ont pas les moyens financiers
pour se permettre de payer un data plan.
Ils n'ont pas une antenne Syscom
avec la télé et l'internet qui vont avec.
Et ça semble à première vue quelque
chose d'impossible, ça coûte très cher.
Un hotspot professionnel
comme ça coûte 2 000 $.
On parle de 50,
ça fait déjà 100 000,
plus les équipements, etc.
Donc ça coûte très, très cher.
Par contre, on peut toujours essayer
de demander aux gens de nous aider.
Et c'est le contexte
parfait pour le faire.
On peut demander aux sociétés
de Télécom dans les pays développés,
qui ont remplacé leurs anciens hotspots
par une nouvelle génération.
Elles ont les anciens dans une boite.
Donc un morceau de métal
à mettre à la poubelle, au Canada;
vaut de l'or dans ce genre de contexte.
On peut utiliser
ces équipements d'occasion
pour se connecter aux fournisseurs
d'accès internet par satellite,
fibre, ADSL, ce qui est disponible
dans la région dont on parle.
On peut demander à des ingénieurs
de faire un travail bénévole,
gratuitement, pour installer le système
et l'entretenir comme il faut.
Et on peut demander
à la société en général
des dons pour acheter
de la bande passante,
pour payer la connexion via satellite
qui devient de moins en moins chère.
Donc, c'est de plus en plus faisable
d'avoir ce genre de solution.
On est dans un contexte
où le problème ne va pas disparaître,
et la solution est faisable.
Donc, en conclusion
de ce voyage que j'ai fait,
de ma semaine
dans la peau d'un réfugié,
je vous dis trois choses.
Je pense que nous devons
devenir créatifs.
Nous devons regarder les choses
le plus loin possible,
« out of the box » comme on dit souvent,
et surtout de façon plus solidaire.
Nous devons exporter l'espoir,
leur donner la possibilité
de retrouver la dignité de leur vie,
d'avoir de la formation continue,
un micro-travail
s'ils sont connectés à Internet -
ils ont leur smartphone pour le faire -
et de gagner un peu d'argent.
Et surtout, nous devons
reconnecter nos âmes oubliées
qui sont là depuis si longtemps.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)